TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer Show."
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We recently launched a global
series of events for Actions
on Google that include
tutorials on how
to build your first action
and advanced sessions
on how to use the more complex
features of the platform.
By the end of the
event, you'll be
able to build an action
for your community,
such as your hometown,
your professional network,
or perhaps your interest group.
Head on over to the post
linked in the description
below for an intro video and
a link to the event site.
Resonance Audio, or
spatial audio SDK,
enables you to create more
realistic VR and AR experiences
on mobile and desktop.
To accelerate adoption of
immersive audio technology
and strengthen the developer
community around it,
we're open-sourcing
Resonance Audio.
Take a look at the
post for more details
and a link to the
GitHub project.
Firebase Remote Config
is a simple way for you
to change elements of
your app on the fly
just by using the
Firebase console.
And now you can update your
Remote Config values directly
through the new Remote
Config REST API.
Details and a link to
the docs are on the post.
Agones is an open-source
dedicated game-server hosting
and scaling project built
on top of Kubernetes
with the flexibility to meet the
needs of your multiplayer game.
The post has code and links
to get started with the alpha.
You can now connect to the
Google Cloud platform Cloud
Shell directly from
your terminal using
the gcloud command-line tool.
Check out the post for
some cool usage examples.
Hyperparameter tuning
on Google Cloud
uses a Bayesian
optimization approach
that can be applied to
auto-tune parameters
of your machine-learning model
such as learning rate, number
of hidden nodes, and more.
Recently it has advanced
to become smarter, faster,
and more capable.
Take a look at the post linked
in the description below
to learn how to take
advantage of this advancement.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching,
and I'm going
to see you in the next
take, because we're
going to do at least one more.